[Musik]
ein sehr stimmung hält war die übung mit
der schutzmasken ist berufung ein
bisschen ungewohnt wenn man ein bisschen
schräg angeschaut hat war noch
überschüsse hat deswegen auch dorthin
gerade recht getroffen
nagel
[Musik]
die zweite übung hat wurde schnelle
magazin wechsel jeweils obwohl die
magazine auf teilt zwar steckt und dann
holzkasten eigenständig ziel bekämpfen
im noch lang
[Musik]
hoppe schussbahn bahn kennen waffen
abgefeuert offen woher ich höre sie
sechs hemmung behoben haben
[Musik]
wir haben halt mit der wache ausbildung
fortgesetzt und eben mit dem test im
lehrsaal abgeschlossen
der test ist sehr umfangreich hat
gewisse gewisse schwierigkeit und wenn
man so will dann muss man das in china
[Musik]